[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
now it's been three and a half months or
so since my last video
on the fantastic beasts films i've
addressed the characters
and the storyline but haven't discussed
the future films
the film's still on the way in quite
some time
given the volatile state of the world
and the impact that kovid has had on the
film industry
i thought that i would give you guys an
update let me just start off by
saying that there are meant to be five
films in total and we've only had two
so far first we got fantastic beasts
somewhere to find them
which was released in 2016 and then we
got fantastic beasts
the crimes of grindelwald which was
released in 2018.
originally all five films were supposed
to be released following that same
pattern
coming out once every two years
fantastic piece three
however is going to break that pattern
for obvious reasons
a global pandemic they had to
temporarily halt production on the film
and filmmakers set a new projected
release date of november 2021
however provided that the new projected
release date was made at the height of
the pandemic
it would have been a tough projection to
make so in this video
i'm going to discuss where they're at
with the film right now
first of all let me just start off by
saying that i'm glad these films were
pushed back
though i enjoyed the first two films i
think they could have been done
better and the public opinion mimics my
own sentiment
toward the films because of how the
first two films were received
warner brothers even declared last year
that they would be putting an even
greater deal of effort
into the films to come negative reviews
and weak box office receipts of the
whole series
was something which warner brothers
noticed quite suddenly raising serious
concerns about their plans to launch
five series of spin-offs
warner brothers has now shown a great
deal of confidence in giving the third
series
with a great deal of effort not to
replicate the fate of the previous films
this prompted a rewriting of the
screenplay and given that the pandemic
is forcing them to push the release date
back a year
this gives them a lot of time to figure
things out a few months after warner
brothers released their statement
rowling released a statement of her own
where she cited an
incredible vision of where she wants to
go with the series
it has also been reported that harry
potter alumnus steve cloves
joined rolling in the rewriting of the
screenplay so i think that we can expect
some really great things
with a lot of negative press currently
being directed at disney
kathleen kennedy and how the star wars
sequel trilogy was handled
it definitely makes sense for warner
brothers to take their time
and give us quality rather than quantity
in a recent interview featuring daisy
ridley
she revealed information which shed
light on the fact that the star wars
sequel trilogy
was not properly thought out and handled
rather haphazardly
given that the harry potter fanbase is
just as large as the star wars fan base
i'm sure warner brothers are going to
tread carefully as they won't want to
make the same mistakes that disney did
as we have only been given 40 of the
films so far
there are still so many gaps and holes
in the story that need to be filled in
the first film took place in the year
1926 the second in 1927
and the last most likely takes place in
or perhaps a bit later as we know that
grindelwald the main antagonist
is defeated in 1945 we've got 18 years
of
information to fill in so i'm really
curious about what year it will be
when the third installment begins should
we expect a bit of a time jump
i think that the ending of the last film
would certainly support this
now other than the main reason for the
film being pushed back
kovid i have also seen some rumors
floating around which suggested that the
fantastic beasts film franchise
is going to be cut altogether the reason
for this being the negative attention
that several people involved with the
film
are currently facing however in spite of
all these things
eddie redmayne shed some light on this
revealing that the show will go on
it's happening and it's really exciting
in fact just this month
fantastic beasts 3 is reported to have
begun filming again
they released a statement a little while
ago saying they would resume in
september
and it seems like they're on track as
they are reported to have started at the
beginning of this month
photos from the backlot of leavesden
studios were recently leaked which
showed a fantastic beast set depicting
berlin this tells us that at least some
of the film will take place in berlin
germany which makes total sense to me
given the time frame
of the films in addition to that there
may be a chance the film will also be
set in brazil
as rowling potentially leaked this
information in an old tweet
let's just say i really ought to be able
to spell rio de janeiro properly
given how many times i've written and
typed it in the last few months
however this tweet was from november
and given that the direction of the film
has changed massively since then
the screenplay was rewritten this may no
longer be a thing
there have been some reports of actors
being seen on set at leaves in studios
as well
most notably jude law who plays
dumbledore there has also been some
speculation that part three will put a
lot of focus on lord's character
and his involvement with hogwarts school
this may be a good strategy as it will
further tie things together
with the existing magical world that we
know and love
in addition to law being seen on set
actor dan fogler
who plays jacob kowalski has openly
admitted that he has already been in for
a costume fitting
to see if he has put on a quarantine 15.
he expressed that the safety measures
surrounding kovid are being taken
seriously
in the same interview fogle was asked
what old harry potter characters he
would like to see be
injected into the film and to this he
goes off on a tangent about hagrid
there's already been some speculation
that hagrid will be in the films at some
points or another
and i think it would be a massive
disservice to films if he wasn't placed
in them in some way
i also don't think that it's a
coincidence that eddie redmayne
who plays newt scamander also revealed
that he would like to see hagrid in the
films
in a reddit ama redmayne was asked which
character would you like to see star
in fantastic piece 3 to which he replied
with an enthusiastic
hagrid hagrid always hagrid the crimes
of grindelwald takes place in the year
with grindelwald still very much on his
rise to power the film closes in this
same year
and grindelwald still has so much
character development to undergo
as does everyone else hackwood starts at
hogwarts in the year 1940.
five years before grindelwald is
defeated we also know that the upcoming
films
may place more of an emphasis on
hogwarts so it's really looking good
that hagrid will make an appearance
which i'm sure will make fans happy but
it's also worth mentioning that a lot of
people went to hogwarts between the
years 1927
and 1945 perhaps most notably a certain
dark wizard
lord voldemort that's right tom riddle
started at hogwarts in the year 1938
and i can't wait to see if and how he is
integrated into the film
if he wasn't introduced in some way i
just don't think it would make any sense
he's the most talented student during
his time at hogwarts and the wizarding
world is facing a huge threat
how could he not be involved bearing all
of this in mind i'm extremely excited
for all of the films to come
the first two were decent but not
amazing and i'm really happy that
they've taken the time to take a step
back
and focus on things more clearly we want
a refined
final product that serves as an
integration to the existing harry potter
films
not some prequel trilogy that takes away
from the magic
what do you guys think are you excited
for the fantastic beasts films
what did you think of the first two
which harry potter characters
do you think we'll see in the third
installment let me know down in the
comment section
below until next time you're a wizard
[Music]
harry
you